okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
i am on some kind of uh pseudo vacation
not in my usual place
so i was gonna have an exotic backdrop
but that doesn't work technically so
i've got even more a boring backdrop
um and uh i've been wandering around
this island all day so i'm i'm probably
still looking a bit overheated
but um
all right we've got a bunch of questions
that were saved up from previous times
oh here's a fun one from derrick
the question is why are there no trees
in the ocean
well let's see
you know let's start off with what the
difference between plants
and things that live in the ocean are
likely
a
like
so one key feature of plants is they
have photosynthesis
is to use energy for sun
to
succeed in making uh energy for
themselves
and they do that by having
uh they do that mostly with their leaves
and um they're they're making use of
um
the they're making use of the light of
the sun to do that
if you are under water then except in a
very narrow
zone
uh close to the surface of the water
that sunlight doesn't get through to you
enough that you could really use
photosynthesis as a source of energy so
the idea of having leaves with um
chloroplasts and things in them to do
photosynthesis
is um uh and using chlorophyll which is
what makes plant green leaves green um
as as a way to get energy isn't going to
cut it you know it's interesting
chlorophyll
is a very clever molecule it's a protein
but it has some uh it has these kind of
clever quantum effects that it uses to
take photons of light from the sun and
succeed in making energy and it's only
in fairly recent years that's been
there's been a somewhat decent
understanding of how that process works
and i think it's fair to say that plants
fundamentally use quantum mechanics in
some sense too in their mechanism for
making energy through chlorophyll and so
on but any case that that mechanism in
the first i don't know a few feet tens
of feet maybe of the ocean there's still
enough sunlight that you can have like
green algae that still have have i think
have scarfal in them as a way to make
energy but by the time you're deeper
than that you're dealing with red algae
and so on you're dealing with things
that that don't
um that don't get their energy um by
having uh light from from the sun
and i think
so that's a um
uh sort of a fundamental reason
for sort of things with leaves and so on
and uh
by the way also
an important feature
of
um
the way trees work is they have this you
know the woody pieces xylem or whatever
which has all these little channels in
it
that allow it to pull water
from its roots up
to um
uh the you use um uh use the mechanism
of evaporation from leaves and so on as
a way to produce pressure that pulls
water up into the into the leaves of the
of the plants and so on into the into
the upper parts of the plant again not a
mechanism that one would expect to want
to use
in the case in the ocean now another
thing about about trees i guess is that
if you're a tree one of the important
things is to stick your head out high
enough
so to speak that you can get your leaves
to actually see the sunlight and if
you're a tree in a forest
and there are lots of other trees there
there's sort of a struggle for who can
get their leaves out
uh you know as the uppermost thing so
that they get lots of sunlight and so
they're not shaded by lots of other
trees
and so i think that's sort of a
motivation for a tree to just grow
bigger taller um all the time and that
motivation in most of the ocean isn't
going to be very useful because growers
you might you're not realistically going
to grow you know half a mile up through
the ocean to get to the point where you
can um
you can get um
uh
um
you can you can have um uh you can get
energy from the sun so to speak so i
think that's some that will be another
sort of the the big idea of trees that
have this very solid trunk
that lets you sort of support leaves
very high up i i don't think is so
likely to be a thing in the ocean i
think it also probably doesn't help
there's another question i don't really
know the answers to
a tree
uh obviously is subject to wind
the wind will make the tree kind of uh
if there's a strong wind it will push
the tree in some direction and so on and
if um uh and there's a question of sort
of how how strong the tree needs to be
to to
uh to not be destroyed by the wind like
i'm right now on an island called
nantucket
that has very strong winds a lot of the
time and you notice that a lot of the
trees are very uh not tall at all and
they're very you can tell they're kind
of they exist in the form they exist
because they have to withstand
high winds for much of the year
so the question is in the ocean where
there are ocean currents i don't know
what the relative forces exerted on a
kind of ocean tree by ocean currents
will be relative to the force of wind
exerted on a on an ordinary you know
tree um on land but i think that might
be a factor that's very hard to have a
rigid object that would be successfully
kind of um
sort of grow up in the in the ocean
because i i don't know but i think it
may be that the forces associated with
ocean currents will be enough to um uh
to kind of destroy any sort of material
that you try to set up in that way now i
suppose i can't be completely correct
about that because
something like an oil rig that has some
uh you know as a drilling platform or
something that has great big steel
supports um it is not it is obviously
subject to those same ocean currents but
on the other hand it's been made of
steel which is a stronger material
although not much
than um
uh than things like like wood of trees
but so i'm not sure that i i've um um
the um
um
uh not sure how successfully i'm
answering this but i think the um so the
motivation for having a tree-like thing
with with woody stuff and leaves of the
green and and um and so on it doesn't
really work the same way in the ocean
and instead what you end up with is is
lots of uh kind of algae that um you
know big pieces of seaweed that that
stretch a long way but they're very
floppy and they just sort of they they
float in the ocean currents and so on i
think rather than being this kind of
rigid structure that you see in trees on
land
um an interesting question i don't know
the answer to
is one of the characteristic features of
trees is these phytotaxis spirals that
you get when they produce successive
shoots
um they will tend to always be at this
137.5 degree angle relative to each
other because that's the angle that well
it's produced by a rather simple process
of kind of diffusion of plant hormones
in the growing plant but it also has the
effect that sort of successive branches
uh least shade all the other branches
that come before them and you see the
same kind of phylotaxis spiral on pine
cones on the the leaf stars of palm
trees on the structure of raspberries on
all kinds of succulent plants all kinds
of places you'll see the same uh same
fire attacks as spiral and as i think
about it i don't remember immediately uh
aquatic examples of that i don't know
cases where
uh in kind of uh aquatic algae type life
sort of the the phytotaxis spirals have
been discovered it existed in in uh you
can find fossil plants from the cambrian
period for example to already show
evidence of these kinds of things um but
i don't know whether it's been sort of
discovered by algae or whether algae
kind of need it um maybe they don't
because they don't have the same sort of
issue of uh avoid shade type thing
so anyway a a rough approximation to um
to an answer to that question
um
let's see
[Music]
um huh
aaron is referring to previous stream
where i said that one of the books i had
for potential beach reading actor but i
haven't been to a beach actually yet
this week but um uh is was emmanuel
kant's critique of pure reason
and yes i got through the first few
pages but i haven't gotten any further
yet
my main takeaway so far you know kant
wrote a bunch
about kind of how to think about our
view of the world so to speak and what
is kind of
uh
you know how
how our sense of the world relates to
what actually exists in the world and
things like this
and i have to say that having thought
a lot particularly recently in
connection with our physics project
about questions like that i just feel
much more empowered to read what what
kant had to say than i ever felt in the
past because in the past i was like
reading this stuff and i just don't it's
hard to understand
um and i just didn't have sort of a
framework to put it into
let's see
um
well there's some questions here about
some
um okay there's a question from zaden
the difference what is the difference in
relation between computing and modeling
you know
okay let's see what i can do with that
so what is computing
computing
tends to be
you have certain
defined by a program
and computing is about taking different
inputs that you can provide applying
those rules and getting outputs so for
example you might have a program that
computes some mathematical kind of thing
you might have a program that generates
some image or something from certain
input so the typical picture of what
computing
is the sort of the typical idealization
of computing is there's a program that
defines a set of rules for going from an
input to an output
and often
in sort of the simplest models of
computing
it's really all about input to output
and the journey of what happens in
between is not so important now
realistically when we run computers
today and we've got our interactive you
know
our operating system and running all
kinds of interactive applications the
interactivity of those applications is
in some sense part of the journey things
the applications progressively do
are sort of part of the of the journey
and maybe we are providing additional
input by clicking the mouse or doing
this or that thing but it's it's a
little bit different than the
traditional input rules output type
model of computing
okay so
and
what do we typically do we typically say
well we want to write a program that
does something useful to us that takes
our input
and produces something that we care
about as output
okay what's modeling
modeling is all about
taking something that otherwise exists
in the world
and finding some way to
idealize that so that we can for example
with a computer
reproduce the essence of what we see in
that system in the real world
so
the
usually those systems in the real world
they tend to be sort of dynamic kinds of
things where there's a process that's
going on and the question is can we
successfully reproduce
the essential features of that process
and i keep on saying the central
features because as soon as you're
saying well i want to make a model for
the growth of a snowflake or something i
want to make a model for the growth of a
tree
you're when you make that model you
don't expect that you're going to
reproduce exactly what every molecule in
the snowflake or the tree does
rather you want to say well i want to
get the basic idea of what happens in
the snowflake or the tree but one
person's basic idea might be very
different from somebody else's basic
idea one person might really really care
about the precise temperature gradients
inside the snowflake another person
might just say i want to know roughly
what shape it is
is it very tree-like or is it very
hexagonal what is it one person might
care about the the basic arrangement of
branches on a tree another might care
about what the overall shape of the
canopy of the tree is
and so at different
models for a single phenomenon in the
world there may be many different models
for that phenomenon depending on what it
is that you think you care about
now there's a question how do you make
those models how do you figure out the
idealization of what the system does so
that you can reproduce the thing you
care about about the system
so for example you might say
you've got a pendulum swinging backwards
and forwards where you've got a planet
going around orbit around a star how do
you make a model for that that captures
whatever it is you care about about it
like where's the pendulum going to be at
a certain time where's the planet going
to be at a certain time
the sort of the a big tradition of
modeling that developed in the 1600s is
this idea of using mathematical
equations to make models so writing down
an equation
that says
there is a function of time that
determines when the planet where the
planet will be at a certain time
i think and i've just actually been
working on this in in sort of the
frontiers of my basic science efforts
um i think one can actually identify
well now for sort of periods of broad
periods of sort of the modeling as done
in science
and the first period one might call kind
of a structural paradigm for modeling
that was a thing that originated in
antiquity when people had the very good
idea that all these different things in
the world might be made of a fairly
small number of common elements
sometimes they thought those elements
were you know fire and water and air and
so on now we think of those elements as
being atoms or molecules and
and so on but this idea that uh even the
larger scale and just atoms and
molecules and things that somehow you
might be able to describe the things a
thing does by talking about what its
elements do and that there might be a
modest number of elements that operate
with
certain characteristics
and i think the the typical thing in
antiquity and for the ancient greeks and
people like that is how is the thing
built up out of atoms out of this side
of that what is its structure
it's sort of a structural paradigm to
thinking about modeling things it's not
very dynamic it's not about how does
this thing kind of sing and dance and
change and apply rules it's about what
is the structure that gets built up and
that was seen in the you know in ancient
greek times when people were talking
about you know epic cycles for where the
the you know the planets might move on
these kind of crystal spheres that have
a certain structure and that was kind of
that paradigm the big thing in the 1600s
was the idea of let's introduce a new
piece of raw material for making models
of things which is mathematical
equations let's write down an equation
usually there were differential
equations using calculus
that would describe
this question of what happens as a
function of time
well another paradigm for modeling which
is one that i was much involved in
introducing in the 1980s is this kind of
computational paradigm for modeling
where instead of saying we've got an
equation and it describes as a function
of time
what's what's happening rather what we
have here is something that um
actually this that term as a function of
time i should uh i should remember to
to mention this piece that i'm writing
because that's a good perhaps way to
describe some things but in any case the
um uh in in the case of um the sort of
computational paradigm it's instead the
system operates according to certain
rules that you can embody in a program
and you can say the system starts this
way and then you apply these rules
and this and this and this thing happens
in the system
so
in a sense
modeling in the computational paradigm
is very much like running programs and
computing that's kind of what the idea
of the computational paradigm is
but there is a bit of a difference
because in a sense in
in typically in computing it's like i
want to get some answer i don't care how
the program works inside i just want to
get this answer in modeling you're much
more concerned with i want to kind of
see at least certain aspects of the
steps because that's the story of what
the system that i'm doing
that i'm looking at does and so there's
more of a kind of look inside the thing
to see a little bit more what the
mechanism is now you don't want to look
too far because in the end a model is a
kind of abstract idealization of the
system if you're doing models with the
with differential equations you don't
imagine that the planet has a
differential equation solving pieces of
software inside it instead it's just the
planet behaves as if it is following
what the differential equation says
so i think that
in a sense the motivation of modeling is
a little different than the motivation
of computing because the motivation of
modeling tends to be we see these things
in the world now let's get a program
that reproduces what those things in the
world do whereas computing tends to be i
have a thing
an idea that i want to execute
now i'll let you write a program that
executes that idea it's a little
different now something that goes sort
of in between those two is machine
learning where you'll typically have
something where you say
here's a set of things here's a set of
examples of how things work in the world
i want to train my program i want to
create a program-like thing that has
been trained based on these examples to
do uh to do the the the things that that
i want to or to follow those examples in
some way so i think
the um
the certain interplay here
is between
uh on on one side computing is about
sort of answering or
doing
solving a problem you want to solve
just working out from input output
something whereas modeling is more about
uh reproducing the important aspects of
every stage and the progress of some
particular system and as i say in the
previous paradigms for modeling um
it was very different from this sort of
computational paradigm in previous
paradigms for modeling you would just
say this thing is described by this
mathematical function not there are
progression of steps like in a program
that specify how the system should
behave now one thing to realize about
models is
when when you write a program for
computing something you usually kind of
have in mind the objective of that
computation when you model something the
only objective you have is make it do
something like what the system does but
the system itself may not have the same
kind of global objective or usually
won't have the same kind of company
identified as having the same kind of
global objective you know when you have
a flow of some fluid or something it
just does what it does it doesn't have a
global objective in the same way that a
program that you write for some
particular purpose of computing
something will tend to have a sort of
global purpose
let's see
um
lots of questions here
why are thorium nuclear fission reactors
not more popular you know it's strange i
i live in a strange world because i was
literally talking to somebody about
uh something which leads to a discussion
of thorium reactors just this morning
i was talking to a person who is a a
long time expert on particle
accelerators
and one of the applications for particle
accelerators is thorium reactors okay
let me try and explain a little bit
about how these things work so
your average nuclear power station the
way it works is it has a bunch of
uranium or plutonium in
uh in
in it and those
elements
have the property
that they are radioactive and in
particular
they with some probability a nucleus of
uranium
would break into
and uh kind of spray pieces of itself
all over the place
it does that
sufficiently slowly
that you can
that it's actually been there's uranium
that has sort of been waiting to do that
for billions of years since the earth
was formed so when you mine uranium out
of the ground one of its isotopes
uranium-235 that means it has some
235 neutrons plus protons in the nucleus
the um
it has it has 92 protons
and uh
the remainder
let me not embarrass myself by doing the
arithmetic wrong the remainder of its
235
particles in its nucleus are neutrons
so anyway uh with the
on
the the uranium that existed when the
earth was formed
is
is still
with some small probability
self-destructing so the average time it
takes for a uranium
235 nucleus to self-destruct is like a
couple of billion years
so still left over from when the earth
was formed 4.6 billion years ago there's
still a bunch of uranium-235 that exists
so you mine uranium and you can put a
bunch of uranium 235 for example into
the nuclear reactor and uh
some of those atoms of uranium-235 that
the nuclei will self-destruct
every time a nucleus self-destructs
it spews out
fragments which include a bunch of
neutrons
and those neutrons then
go hit other uranium
and when a neutron hits the uranium
nucleus the
nucleus
will spontaneous will self-destruct
it will spontaneously self-destruct with
some very slow at some very slow rate
but if you hit it with a neutron it will
just go kapoon and
uh and immediately
so
what happens in a nuclear reactor is
that you have a chain reaction
you
[Music]
force other
uranium nuclei to start to
to
break apart
those
things that break apart produce even
more neutrons
and
that
um
uh and so then they make even more uh
uranium nuclei fall apart and so on
when you make a
happening is but that's all happening
sort of explosively it starts off with
the chain reaction starts off and it
kind of grows exponentially you know two
neutrons turning four neutrons down
eight neutrons and so on as they as they
make other nuclei fall apart in a
nuclear reactor you have control rods
that basically have moderator that kind
of
keeps these neutrons from so from sort
of going and destroying other nuclei and
you can kind of control the rate at
which um these neutrons are propagated
through the core of the reactor and you
can kind of keep the reactor away from
going critical so to speak and ending up
having uh something where it can i can
generate too much heat and melt down in
the sense that it uh
if
when all these nuclear reactions are
taking place and
nuclei are falling apart that's
generating lots of energy that that ends
up as heat and if there's too much of it
it will mean that this lovely nuclear
reactor that you have that's where a
bunch of metal structure in it will all
melt and that's what happened for
example at fukushima and it's what's
happened what happens when there are
sort of typical accidents in nuclear
reactors
is it melts down in the sense that
everything gets too hot and the
structure and the fuel rods and all
these and the moderator and all this
kind of thing that kept the reactor
under control
it's all
all goes away
okay so enter thorium thorium is an
element which doesn't
um which has the property that it will
undergo
uh
fusion undergo friction that its nuclear
will fall apart
but it needs a little bit of a kick to
do that
and you can give it a kick by using a
particle accelerator to just take a
bunch of protons accelerate them with
magnets make them go very fast ram them
into the thorium nuclei and that will
cause the thorium nuclei to
self-destruct and that as those ones
self-destruct they start a little
reaction where more of them
self-destruct more and more but the
reaction doesn't
doesn't go on
uh in the same way that it does in your
uranium reactor at least that's my
understanding of how it works and so
it's kind of a way to to have something
where um there's no way to make a bomb
out of it because you just can't it
doesn't spontaneously
there's no spontaneous process
of um of having the thing uh generate
undergo efficient and generate more
neutrons and so on
but as soon as you kick it
right sort of where you kicked it
something will happen and it will
generate energy from the breaking apart
of these nuclei so in order to make this
work you need a a particle beam a beam
of high energy protons let's say to to
to make this work but the energy you
need to produce that beam behind your
protons is presumably much smaller than
the energy associated with uh with the
with what comes out from the nuclear
processes in the thorium at least that's
my my understanding now why why i think
people have worked on
trying to make sort of reality out of
this i don't know precisely the status
of that
i will say i learned another thing about
sort of uses of particle beams
in in sort of things related to nuclear
reactors which is one of the problems
with nuclear reactors is they produce
nuclear waste
nuclear waste is random isotopes
random elements that
uh and here's how it usually works when
for example uranium
undergoes fission it will fall apart
into smaller nuclei
and they'll be just sort of random
smaller nuclei
so might be a nucleus which has some a
very short lifetime so the uranium
nucleus will fall apart it will produce
you know some weird isotope of copper or
something and that isotope of copper
will decay in a microsecond some other
isotope of i don't know zinc or
something and that will decay to
something else and so on and so on and
so on and so on as that
process
basically happens so long as all you get
are isotopes that dictate quickly until
you get to a stable isotope you're good
you don't leave over any kind of
radioactive waste the bad case is if
this chain of reactions
leads you to something like strontium-90
or cobalt what is it called um there's
an isotope of cobalt which has this
property as well
and the problem with these isotopes is
they aren't stable they're radioactive
but they have a very long half-life of
like 100 years let's say or something
like that so if you end up with you know
making randomly as you kind of spray out
different fragments of the uranium
nuclei and things if one of those
fragments is a strontium nucleus um then
you can end up with something which has
a lifetime of hundreds of years and so
you can end up with something which is
not stable it's not not radioactive it's
still and it's not so radioactive that
it will decay in a microsecond or
something but it's still radioactive so
it can cause trouble and it can get into
groundwater and it can make you know all
sorts of terrible things radioactive and
so on and so the difficulty is these
sort of intermediate length intermediate
time scale radioactive elements
radioactive isotopes it's kind of a
strange thing that the same process of
radioactivity can have vastly different
lifetimes can lead to for example alpha
emission
the emission of a of a helium before
there's two protons two neutrons which
is a pretty common way that that
radioactive nuclei fall apart as they
emit an alpha particle which is that two
protons two neutrons thing and they do
that and that causes them to turn into
another isotope which might again emit
an alpha particle or it might emit a
electron or it might sound like a
spontaneous fission or it might have
some other decay process that makes it
radioactive but one of the things that's
sort of mysterious is that alpha
emission there are uh examples of alpha
emission where the half-life the the
expected time before the alpha particle
is emitted is microseconds or billions
of years and it's very rare that there
are things that span that many sort of
different orders of magnitude for a
phenomenon and actually the reason it
happens that way is because it's sort of
a mathematical fact that it's an
exponential function that appears in the
probability
for alpha emission and the way that
works is um essentially what's happening
is
the way you can think about it as a
quantum mechanical phenomenal tunneling
and essentially what happens is
um if you have something where
okay so you have let's say you're
rolling a ball downhill
and the the ball is at the top of the
hill it has lots of potential energy and
as it rolls down the hill that potential
energy is turned into kinetic energy the
ball rolls faster and faster under
gravity it just does what it does okay
now let's imagine there's a big bump in
the hill there's a big
there's a you know it's running down and
then it runs into this bump and it that
bump is pretty high and it can't the the
kinetic energy that it got running down
to that bump is not enough to get it
over the pump
and so in ordinary classical physics
it's like it doesn't get over the bump
the thing just stops and it can't get
any further but in quantum mechanics
there's a phenomenon called tunneling
that you can see is kind of a result of
of ferrous on certainly principal
arguments and things
but basically what happened well the
general idea of quantum mechanics is
it is not the case that sort of definite
things happen in systems instead the
systems kind of sniff out all possible
parts for everything that could happen
and what we get to work out is just
probabilities for different things to
have happened in the system
and so what happens in this case of of
you know when you have
the equivalent of the ball rolling
downhill and this big bump
is that in quantum mechanics there will
be
some kind of possibility that the ball
will do this weird thing that doesn't
really conserve energy in a sense and it
manages to to jump over the bump and
come out the other and go down the other
side
but
the way quantum mechanics works there's
a small probability of that happening
but that probability gets exponentially
smaller the bigger the energy gap is
and so what happens in alpha decay is
the same kind of thing there's
essentially a barrier to these alpha
particles uh sort of getting out of the
nucleus to these pieces of the nucleus
that's enough but it's a piece of
nucleus sort of breaking away from this
nucleus getting outside there's kind of
an energy barrier that prevents that
happening and the height of that energy
barrier determines
the
uh
the the what the probability of that
happening is every at every moment it's
like there's an alphabetical rattling
around it wants to get out and the
question is is it going to make it out
or not
and the question whether it makes it out
or not there's a certain probability it
makes it out at every second or
something and that probability is
determined by
the height of this barrier and it is an
exponential dependence on the height of
a barrier now an interesting question is
is there an easy way to derive that
exponential
and for example in our new models of
physics
is there an easy way to understand why
tunneling involves an exponential uh
degradation as a function of energy and
i think i did think about this at some
point i think there may be an argument
for that um i can't immediately
reproduce it but basically the the fact
that this alpha decay phenomenon has
this vastly different from microseconds
to billions of years
possibility for the average time before
the alpha particle comes out that the
lifetime for decay of the nucleus is a
consequence of this exponential factor
from tunneling but anyway that that's
some uh but so i was going to say when
when you have a nuclear reactor and it
has nuclear fission going on that means
nuclear eyes are being sprayed apart
into all these different pieces and the
bad case is one one of those pieces
happens to be a century-ish
lifetime or even a few years even a
decade or something lifetime nucleus um
because then it can uh it won't decay to
nothing
it'll be hanging out it'll be
radioactive radioactivity causes all
kinds of trouble for us humans it's kind
of bad news
um so i mean i should say why does
radioactivity cause trouble for us
humans well what happens is when there's
radioactivity you have a um
the uh
you you're getting these particles like
an alpha particle for example emitted
and they're going these particles going
very fast so when these particles go
through a tissue
through you for example
they if they're if they they will
disrupt the atoms that are in you
because when they when they zip past
they're like applying this there's some
electrical force that they're applying
to the atoms in you and that will tear
those atoms apart and in particular uh
it does very bad things to dna for
example and it will tend to destroy the
genetic material in dna
it will tend to produce sort of changes
in genetic material that can lead to
cancer things like that in general with
enough radiation you just kill cells and
that's indeed what you do
in radiation therapy for cancer for
example that's indeed what you're trying
to do
you're trying to say this little spot of
cells is a tumor and it's growing
without bound and it's bad let's kill it
off and so you concentrate this
radiation on that particular spot to
kill off those particular cells and
radiation kills cells by a variety of
methods but one of them is is destroying
sort of the genetic information
in dna and so on so and that that's what
and usually you know if you if you get
uh exposed to radiation all sorts of
terrible things happen but there's sort
of a whole cascade of things that happen
that depend a little bit on the lifetime
of cells like you know there'll be
things with blood cells that last
you know where the last three months or
something and then as the next
generation is supposed to be produced it
doesn't succeed in getting produced
because because there's radiation damage
to the genetic material and so on so
that that's sort of how that how that
comes about
but any case the question is if you've
got this nuclear waste what are you
going to do with it
and you know if there's all this
radioactive stuff that might be
radioactive for thousands of years even
what do you do with it and so people
have tried to figure out where do you
put nuclear waste
and so for example the uh there's a lot
of controversy about oh do you put it in
some you know do you put it in a deep
mine where you bury it underground
and uh do you put it do you encase it in
glass
so that it's sort of more kept away from
the elements if you put it deeper if you
bury it on the ground there's a problem
that it can kind of seep out and get
into ground water
ground water can go other places and
that's bad
it's you know if you could like uh
send it uh you know you can kind of
you can you can try and put it somewhere
you could maybe send it into space you
could you know if you if you had enough
effort you could throw it into the sun
or something and that would definitely
be a good way to dispose of it um i
actually just recently found a funny
essay that i wrote when i was like 11
years old about um problems like that
which concluded that the right answer
was to make spacecraft that would do
sort of garbage disposal by throwing
suns into the sun but it's a rather
impractical kind of solution um it was
that and it still is a rather
impractical solution
in any case one of the exotic
possibilities for getting rid of nuclear
waste is what if you just zap the
nuclear waste with a particle beam if
you do that it's kind of like what's
happening in the thorium reactor you're
kind of zapping it and you're causing
these nuclei that um right now it's a
radioactive nuclei and things you're
breaking up those nuclei and you're
causing them and the next kind of random
role of the dice what happens when you
break up the nucleus the chances are
you're not going to get one of these
troublesome isotopes anymore and i think
it's the case that by the time you get
down to the lighter elements there are
no troublesome isotopes anymore so
they're either either things disappear
quickly or they are basically stable and
don't cause trouble normally that can
quite be correct because tritium
uh the isotropic of hydrogen that has
proton and two neutron
nucleus it has a half-life of about
maybe 10 years or something um i know
that that was a funny phenomenon that
from the nuclear tests that were done in
the atmosphere in the 1950s there is a
bunch of tritium in seawater that kind
of spread itself throughout the oceans
of the earth
and uh when i was a kid at least and you
asked how much tritium is there in a
typical sample of hydrogen there was one
number the number is different today
because the tritium that existed from
the bomb tests that have been done in
the 50s was still around when i was
first learning about chemistry and
things in the 1960s
and so it still contributed to the
diffraction of hydrogen that is tritium
and is pretty much all decayed by now
and so it no longer makes a contribution
there
all right let's see
um
it's coming from i see about since with
dna being a double helix shouldn't work
with something like error correcting
codes yeah well
dna
does have proofreading enzymes
that try to check that
it's sort of correct so here's a you
know basically what happens is dna is
transcribed to rna
then what happens is every three base
pairs of the dna or the rna which is in
other words every every three of those
things you know the acgt
um
those are the two pairings um every one
of those base pairs what is a base pair
a base pair is a cluster of i don't know
a few tons of atoms um on this backbone
of the dna so the dna might you know
chromosome might have
100 million uh different base pairs each
one is either an a a g a c or a t
and um when to say one of those letters
is to say it has a particular cluster of
atoms that is strung along this backbone
and so you know our genetic material our
genetic code is encoded in that sequence
of a's and g's and c's and t's
okay when
the genetic code is used to produce
proteins
um the proteins the way it works says
that every
three
uh of these
base pairs like a g c or something might
be a a triple base pairs every one of
those makes the so-called codon and
every codon codes for an amino acid and
there are about 20 amino acids that at
least we use and those amino acids are
the building blocks of proteins proteins
are sequences of amino acids strung
together
and each time there's a sequence of
three base pairs it makes one of these
codons which codes for one of the amino
acids okay so important point if you
have four possible base pairs
that means that that the number of
possible triples of base pairs
is
um uh four cubed um
which is which is 64. and that means
there are 64 possible codons that you
can get but there are only 20 amino
acids
so in the early days of dna people
thought oh biology must have discovered
error correcting codes just like we
humans have and there must be some
elaborate way of doing this coding that
very carefully
optimally error corrects it doesn't seem
to work quite that way but nevertheless
it is the case that there are legal and
illegal codons
and there are proofreading enzymes that
can go down a dna strand and kind of uh
fix the ones that are obviously wrong
but so in that sense that that can be
done and when dna replicates it is
common for there to be some amount of of
error in the replication when when the
two strands of dna peel apart um and uh
and then another strand is filled in
alongside the the strand that sort of
zipped apart um there's a question of
does the strand that fills in exactly
and correctly match um you know c with g
a with t and so on or are there errors
and there's a small rate of errors and
that small rate of errors is actually in
the end not bad because that's what
leads to the random mutations that drive
biological evolution but
the the the actual rate of errors
is higher than you would want from
biological evolution and so these these
proofreading mechanisms come in and try
and fix the obvious errors so to speak
um and uh
that
so that reduces the rate of errors to
something much smaller
it's a little different for viruses and
things like that they have different
mechanisms for doing that
well let's see
um
okay there's a com
comment i think it's about nuclear waste
here
um
uh
if you dilute
the nuclear waste back to the same
concentration as the ore and put it back
in the mine would that be a problem yes
there is a problem because what you got
out of a mine is uranium what you're
putting back is one of the fishing
products of uranium which may be
something much nastier than uranium so
it's not good enough to just say
uh replace put it put it back to the
same place where you were because you
don't have the same place where you were
i mean it's it's worth realizing
that
in
uh
different you know when you do chemistry
you say i've got
it's hydrogen it's carbon it's gold
whatever else and whatever atoms of coal
gold or carbon or whatever you have
that's the number of atoms the number of
atoms you put in is the number of atoms
you get out you can't transmute an atom
of lead into an atom of gold for example
that was the goal of the alchemists
throughout the middle ages and beyond
sort of the the thing that people really
wanted to do with chemistry was to find
a way to turn base metals like lead into
gold which was sparkly and shiny and
valuable and so they wanted to just by
chemistry turn lead into gold but wasn't
possible because what turns out to be
the case is that whether your lead or
goal is determined by the structure of
the atomic nucleus and chemistry is just
about
changing
the the electrons and the way the
electrons kind of wrap around the
nucleus and how those electrons cause
different atoms to be close to each
other and about be bound in with the uh
with with the chemical bonds and so on
and it's not about changing the
structure of the nucleus
so these ideas so in order to change the
structure of nucleus you need a nuclear
process
and that means like if you zap
lead with uh with a particle beam for
example you might be able to turn a
little bit into gold um that's a bit but
you have to zap the nucleus with a
particle beam to change the structure of
the nucleus
and so that's what so so there's no
purely chemical process
which can change radioactive waste into
something that's not going to be
radioactive because you need to change
the atomic nuclei and that's what not
what chemistry does you might be able to
use chemistry to separate out um one
particular one kind of chemical element
for another one of the things that
chemistry does
is it can separate one element i don't
know it could separate lithium from
beryllium or something
but it cannot separate uh one isotope of
lithium from one isotope of beryllium so
for example when you have water there
are different isotopes you know ordinary
water just has hydrogen with a single
proton
in its nucleus but there's heavy water
which has hydrogen uh which which has a
hydrogen in which there's a proton and a
neutron deuterium it's called uh is as
the um uh as the hydrogen so for example
d2o is just like water
and as far as chemistry is concerned as
far as the electron properties it is
basically just like water but as far as
the nuclear properties are concerned
heavy water is very different from
ordinary water heavy water is actually
very useful in nuclear reactors because
it absorbs neutrons a lot whereas
ordinary water doesn't absorb them
nearly as much but as far as chemistry
is concerned you pretty much it's not
quite true for heavy water heavy water
has slightly different characteristics
for chemistry but most of the time
different isotopes by the time you're
heavier elements different isotopes
don't have different chemical properties
they only have different nuclear
properties so no chemical process can
separate isotopes so for example one of
the big things that's necessary for
making with the nuclear reactors and so
on is the separation of uranium-238 from
uranium-235
and there's no chemical process
alone that does that and so what you
have to do is uh you have to use uh well
you can use some physical processes
because you you can use the fact we can
use gas diffusion because a
uranium-235 atom it has slightly less
mass than a young 238 atom and so when
it's diffusing when it's kind of when
the atoms are bouncing around and moving
a certain distance in a gas the
uranium-235 atoms will move slightly
further than the uranium-238 atoms so
you can use that as a method for
separating these things but there's no
chemical process where you do a chemical
reaction that will tell apart these
isotopes
let's see
um
well i should probably wrap up soon here
but um
um
well
uh
um
oh i'm
being told that the internet connection
here is not perfectly stable well i hope
it's i hope it's been okay um ethan is
asking what is my altcoin portfolio
boy okay that's some uh
uh
i'm actually losing track of what
cryptocurrencies i have stakes in i know
some of the bigger ones but um
they're kind of random and historically
determined maybe for another time we'll
talk about different cryptocurrencies
and how how different cryptocurrencies
work and kind of the different
objectives of different cryptocurrencies
um
maybe let me take one more
uh
um
oh boy a lot of interesting questions
here
ori asks
can the world become more valuable even
though there isn't more stuff being
brought in from outer space
it's an interesting question
so it relates to very foundational
questions about economics
i mean that is you know how much is
the world worth right now
in dollars
if you were going to sort of uh pay for
everything in the world
you know i don't know what it is maybe
100 trillion dollars whatever it is
um what is it the case that over time
that
the
value in dollars of the world will go up
and if so how could that be
and in countries you try and measure
the some kind of uh value i mean it's a
little complicated measuring
the value of something because in a
sense let's say you have an object or a
company something like this you say how
much is it worth
well what that really is asking is if
somebody was going to buy it from you
how much would they pay you for it
okay what does it even mean to buy it
from you it means that if they say oh
we'll buy this company for 100 million
dollars
they're saying that
the they think that that hundred million
dollars that they could be using to buy
candy bars or whatever else
that hundred million dollars is as
usefully
repre as usefully put into owning that
company as it is used for buying candy
bars for example
and so
that
um
is so in other words that there's an
exchange that that the thing that was
worth x number of dollars could be
exchanged for all other things which are
similarly worth x number of dollars in
other words the the concept that
something is worth something is this
idea that there's many different things
you could exchange it with you have this
thing and there are lots of other things
that you could once instead and you are
assigning a value to the thing based on
what the sort of exchange with all these
other possible things would be
so i think when it comes to asking about
the sort of the the overall
well
when you ask about countries for example
you talk about gdp gross domestic
product
um which is more of a revenue
computation than it is a net worth
computation it's more how much money is
churning through the country than it is
how much is this country worth
you can get some estimate how much is a
country worth by asking for things like
you know what's the value of the real
estate in the country what's the value
of all the stocks
of companies in that country all those
kinds of things
but i think one of the one of the sort
of surprises and interesting things is
that there definitely is the impression
that
uh the value of the world is going up
over time
and
why does that why could that possibly
happen
i think the reason that happens is i
think ideas processes discoveries make
the value of the world go up
and i think the reason for that is
that
in some first approximation that the
more we learn about how to do stuff the
more efficiently we can do things and
somehow that translates into the concept
that the things we have so for instance
okay let's take
uh
the raw material for a smartphone
that yeah the question is is a
smartphone
worth more than the sum of its parts
and what what about a smartphone
is worth more than the random pieces of
aluminum and silicon and
tantalum and who knows what else that
goes into a smartphone in what sense is
the is the value of the smartphone as
finished goods greater than the value of
its component parts
and i think that it's that kind of it's
that process
of putting the thing together
into this finished object that is sort
of adding value and you can
progressively add more and more value to
the world as you have more and more
ideas about so how to put together a
taller and taller tower of sort of
sophistication i mean first you have the
smartphones then you have the networks
that can be created by people using
smartphones then you have this they have
that you're building this kind of tower
by ideas that are abstraction and i
think the reason that the value
uh the sort of perceived value of the
world can go up is that it part of the
value has to do with the the sort of
this frontier of new ideas and new
things being constructed and figuring
out how to do more stuff now what does
that really mean i mean i suppose at
some level that means you know we humans
live a certain number of years at least
to present and uh you know there's how
much can we do in that amount of time
how much how much can we achieve
and if we are kind of doing everything
from scratch you know growing our own
food tilling the soil and so on
ourselves there's there's a much less
that we can achieve than if we're making
use of some giant tower of technology
that makes use of all these inventions
and ideas and this and that and the
other to to create kind of a a sort of a
a kind of higher tower of um of
efficiency and i think that the the
maybe a way to think about it is you
know in in in a human lifespan for
example how much can be achieved in some
sense of being achieved and the fact
that that is so much greater for the
fact that there's all of this sort of
this kind of taller platform that we've
built through technology and i think
that's sort of the reason why
it's not just a question of the raw
material in fact i would argue that when
it comes to information technology
and and so on that there's an infinite
amount of value that can be generated
there even with the exact same raw
material that we already have so you
don't need to drag you know the asteroid
made of gold to the earth
to have additional values so to speak
you just have to have this tower of
ideas that in a sense make what the what
the computer does
able to achieve more
for for a person so to speak so i i
think that's my sort of interpretation
of why that it's the it's the
progressive development of ideas the
progressive developments of technology
that leads to increasing overall value
for the world where value is defined
somehow as you know achievement a
lifetime or something
for people um i i don't know whether
that's some uh but it's an interesting
question you know when you look at sort
of the closed system of the world
how do you end up with growing economic
value
through the course of time
given that it's a closed system and it's
not like people are just saying well um
you know i'm it's going to grow in value
because i can sell that particular ore
for more money than i could sell it for
before because well it has this better
use somewhere else and so on once you
have a closed system there are none of
those stories that can be told but i
think the thing that is sort of the
constant of um of this is
you know that the consumption is right
now by humans
and
there's sort of limitations like human
life's plans that determine
kind of that that give you a scale
for for what things are worth now an
interesting question is at a time when
there are bots that are
transacting many of the things in the
world at a time when when
maybe they're humans somewhere in the
loop but a lot of the actual
transactions are happening between ais
um how does that how did everyone then
see kind of the exchange of value and
can it be the case that once there are
you know ai is representing a large part
of the economy well you still get this
notion of increasing value my guess is
the answer is yes
because it's the same idea there is
technology never ends there is always a
way to sort of add to discover more in
technology think of the next thing you
could do
the only thing that defines kind of the
endpoints of technology is what do you
want to do because we can invent all
kinds of wonderful technology to do all
kinds of things that people would look
at and say we don't care
it's not something we care about doing
and what tends to happen is the sort of
co-evaluation
of what technology makes possible with
what it is that people think they want
to do and that kind of spiral sort of
upwards as you imagine your technology
allows you to do more things so you
imagine more that you can do then
technology enables you to do that more
efficiently then you keep going and keep
going keep going um and there are no
doubt many different directions in which
that could go
but that's um
that's kind of the idea and i think that
that spiraling process is what leads to
a an increase of total value so to speak
at an economic level although i have to
say that some details of sort of exactly
how that argument works
i'm i'm not completely clear on and i've
been thinking a bit about some of the
foundations of economics and that's a
good exercise actually to think about um
in terms of understanding that
all right i should wrap up here for now
um but uh
thanks for joining me and um
uh
look forward to uh
another
one of these uh
sessions uh i think same time next week
so thanks for joining and uh bye for now